clear that in-person learning is bad
schools are open
parents want schools open
and experts are clear that in-person
learning is bad
in treatment courses to 20 million
in addition we're working with pfizer to
accelerate the delivery of these pills
and we'll now have the first 10 million
treatment
cycles courses by the end of june
instead of the end of september
these pills can dramatically decrease
hospitalizations and deaths
and are a game changer with the
potential to alter the impact of covet
on people and on our nation
bottom line we have the tools we need to
manage this surge in omicron cases
with that i'll turn it over to dr
wolinski dr wilinski
thank you jeff and good morning everyone
i'd like to start by walking you through
today's data
the current seven-day daily average of
cases is about 491
700 cases per day
an increase of about 98 from the
previous week
the seven day average of hospital
admissions is about 14 800 per day an
increase of about 63 percent over the
previous week
and the seven day average of daily
deaths are about 1200 per day which is
an increase of about five percent over
the prior week
over the last several weeks and over the
holidays we have seen a significant and
rapid increase in covert 19 cases
this increase reflects both cases caused
by the delta variant and more
importantly now cases surging from the
omicron variant
over the past month we have seen the
percentage of omicron cases increase and
the percentage of delta cases decrease
based on cdc genomic sequencing we now
estimate that omicron represents about
95 of cases in the country and delta
represents the remaining five percent of
the cases
the sharp rise in cases and the
emergence of the more transmissible
omicron variant emphasizes the
importance of vaccinations and boosters
this week fda made several vaccine
authorizations and cdc followed these
authorizations by making additional
vaccine recommendations
first cdc authorized uh fda authorized
and cdc recommended shortening the
window in which people who receive the
pfizer covid19 vaccine can get a booster
dose from six months to five months
second fda authorized and cdc
recommended that children ages 5 to 11
who are moderately or severely
immunocompromised
should get an additional primary shot of
the pfizer coven 19 vaccine 28 days
after their second shot to provide them
additional protection
and today cdc's advisory committee on
immunization practices is meeting to
discuss boosters for those 12 to 15
years old
after fda's authorization on monday i
look forward to listening to the
committee's discussion that will take
place this afternoon
current data demonstrate that receiving
a booster dose is critical to provide
protection against covet 19 and the
omicron variant
cdc surveillance data and other studies
from around the world have demonstrated
the benefit of a booster dose after
receiving only a primary series
including decreased risk of infection
severe disease and death caused by covet
19.
in large national studies from israel
comparing those who are boosted with
those who are fully vaccinated a booster
dose decreased infection by 10 times in
all age groups
similarly in those studies boosters
resulted in a decrease in severe disease
in individuals over 60 years old by 18
times and decreased severe disease in
people age 40 to 59 years old by 22
times
and people who received a booster shot
had 90 percent lower mortality due to
cova 19 than those who did not receive a
booster shot
while these studies were done when delta
was the dominant variant in israel we
expect to see a similar trend of
increased protection over those who are
boosted with omicron
vaccines and boosters are protecting
people from the severe and tragic
outcomes that it
can occur from covet 19 infection
we're asking everyone to follow these
four steps
get vaccinated and get boosted if you
are eligible
wear a mask
stay home when you're sick and take a
test if you have symptoms or are looking
for greater extra reassurance before you
gather with others
so with that thank you i will now turn
things over to dr fauci
thank you very much dr wilinski
what i'd like to do over the next couple
of minutes is talk about the omicron
variant and some concerns particularly
in the area of severity of disease if i
can have the first slide
i'm going to focus predominantly on
severity but let me just make a few
comments to underscore many of the
things that dr wolinski said
first of all without a doubt
unequivocally we are dealing with a
highly highly transmissible variant that
spreads rapidly the data are
overwhelming in that regard
number two
immune evasion
omicron evades immune vaccine protection
against symptomatic disease and to some
extent to severe disease however as
underscored by dr wolinski again
laboratory and clinical data indicate
that booster shots
reconstitute vaccine protection even
against omicron
let's spend a moment now on severity of
disease which is less likely that
omicron will cause severe disease i'm
going to give you data from four
separate sources
just to underscore that but then to end
with a caveat next slide
these are data from south africa if you
look at the three variants in blue red
and yellow with omicron being yellow and
take a look at admissions
oxygen necessity necessity
severe disease and death in each case
the yellow bar is significantly less
than the red and the blue bar which
represent beta and delta next slide
if you look at data from the united
kingdom from three separate sources the
uk security agency
the university of edinburgh at scotland
and imperial college
each of these show that in various
parameters of divise severity
omicron appears to be less than delta
next slide
although this data is a bit more
preliminary but nonetheless indications
from houston texas indicate that we are
seeing similar situations here in the
united states next slide
this slide is from canada again
showing that the risk of hospitalization
or death was 65 percent lower
among amicron compared to delta and the
risk of intensive care was 83
next slide
if you go now to in vitro animal studies
these are interesting but remember there
is always a caveat
associated with animal studies
and in a number of studies
ones that have done individually and
pooled
in mice and hamster models it was shown
that the virus of omicron proliferates
very well in the upper airway and
bronchi
but actually very poorly in the lungs
which actually goes along with doesn't
prove but goes along with the concept
that you have a very transmissible virus
with upper airway secretion
but a virus that has less pathogenicity
in the lung
next slide
so let's look at the bottom line of what
i said and i'll get to the caveat in a
moment
multiple sources
of now preliminary data indicate a
degree decrease severity with omicron
however we really do need more
definitive assessment
of severity with longer term follow-up
here
and in different countries
but the big caveat is we should not be
complacent
since the increased transmissibility of
varion maybe vomicron
might be overridden by the sheer volume
of the number of cases that may be of
reduced severity but could still
stress our hospital system
because a certain proportion of a large
volume of cases
no matter what are going to be severe
so don't take this as a signal
that we can pull back from the
recommendations that you just heard from
dr walensky about the need for
vaccination for boostering for wearing
masks and all the other cdc
recommendations so let me close with the
final slide just a word
about children because we're getting
asked about that
the omicron variant so far appears to be
less severe than the delta but remember
the caveat
rapid community of spread is seeing
the larger number of children being
hospitalized
again mostly among the unvaccinated
and about vaccination just to refresh
your memory
the fisa bioentec is now authorized and
recommended for children from five to
seventeen
children from twelve to seventeen can
get a booster the fda authorized to
fifteen and as
he said
today the acip will meet about that for
recommendation
and finally a question that many ask and
i'm sure many of the reporters who have
children are asking this
what about kids from six months to five
years
those studies are ongoing now to get the
right dosage regimen to get to where we
want to be and likely the clinical trial
are ongoing and in in individuals less
than five years hopefully in the first
half
hopefully towards the earlier part of
the first half we may have some
information so that we can vaccinate
children of that age
i'll stop there and back to you jeff
well thank you doctors and with that
let's open it up for some questions
kevin
thanks jeff um we have a lot of
questions today please keep your
questions to one question we'll get
through as many as we can first let's go
to jeannie bauman at bloomberg
all right thank you so much for taking
my question um i know dr wolinski has
said part of the reason that um cdc is
not requiring a a test after five days
of isolation is that's not what the
chests are designed to do so i was just
wondering if there are plans by red x or
other programs to develop tests that
could actually detect you know how
infectious you are how contagious you
are thank you
dr wilson you want to clarify uh the
the yeah
so the fda rapid tests are authorized um
as you say genie for um
diagnosis they are not a quantitative
test they are qualitative tests to
diagnose they're they're authorized for
use in the first seven days of symptoms
um and uh they are authorized for you
serially um in things like test to stay
where you have a negative and an another
negative um you can confirm that people
continue to be negative um maybe i'll
pass it to dr tony uh dr fauci where uh
to talk about red x and what is going on
in the design of other tests for
qualitative quantitative purposes
yeah okay so obviously there's a lot of
work going on
in the uh bioimaging and bioengineering
institute looking at refining and
fine-tuning tests from every aspect from
sensitivity specificity and
predictability and those are ongoing
studies now with a considerable
investment on a number of investigators
thank you next
question let's go to zeke miller at the
ap
um thanks uh uh uh for for doing this
today uh for dr lolinski um i know
there's been a number of questions about
this over the last several months but
given the data you've uh discussed today
about the benefits of booster doses um
and dr factor's comments yesterday about
sort of potential changes to cdc policy
is the cdc going to change its
definition of booster doses or
and then for jeff for people who are not
fully up to date with their vaccination
they're being mean they're eligible but
haven't gotten a booster um
should they be expecting to see you some
you know that's some of the prohibitions
that people who are not fully vaccinated
you know whether it comes to travel or
employment with the federal government
that they would be subject to some of
those prohibitions down the line
dr malinsky first
yeah super thank you zeke so individuals
are considered fully vaccinated against
coven 19 if they've received their
primary series that definition is not
changing but consistent with how public
health has historically viewed or even
talked about how we recommend vaccines
we are now recommending that individuals
stay up to date with additional doses
that they are eligible for and we have
now available um how you can stay up to
date with your cova 19 vaccines based on
what vaccine you have received and what
age group you are in and that is
available now on the cdc website back to
you jeff so zeke to repeat what dr
wolinski just said someone is considered
fully vaccinated if they receive their
primary series of vaccines so if you
think about the different requirements i
think you mentioned travel
the osha and cms rules as other examples
that has not changed and we do not have
any plans to change that
i do think it's really important
to to recognize the vast majority of
hospitalizations and deaths are among
the unvaccinated americans and
completing the primary
vaccination series is clearly a critical
step to prevent severe outcomes with
boosters as dr malinsky said giving the
highest level of protection so we'll
encourage everybody to get vaccinated
and when eligible boosted as to as to
the definition uh someone is considered
fully vaccinated they've received their
primary series of vaccine next question
good jackie heinrich with fox news
thank you guys for doing this briefing
um i wanted to ask about the fda's um
recommendations that have come out since
november uh
and seemingly happening without
consulting uh the panel of independent
experts that were consulted for
uh approvals on the vaccines themselves
has there been a policy change or
uh
sort of a shift away from standard
practice when it comes to
recommendations for boosters versus the
process that everyone went through for
the vaccine itself
well i would defer to the fda and the
specific fda question though i do know
that
fda like cdc where i will ask dr
welinski to comment about her
reliance on the expertise of the asip
does consult with
its experts on a regular basis and
formally convenes them as you know uh
regularly dr malinsky you want to talk
about the cdc experience with your group
of outside experts in the asap yeah
absolutely and thank you for that
question jackie so obviously these are
unprecedented times where there's so
much action happening right now with
regard to vaccination and given those
unprecedented times we've convened our
advisory committee on immunization
practices more than ever before
we had a meeting prior to
the week prior to christmas and we are
now having a meeting today so the week
after new year's
and i am in regular touch in regular
touch with these experts um to ensure
that they are confident as to the
discussions that they feel like need to
be had as we're making decisions about
vaccination for the country
great next question please
go to jeremy diamond at cnn
hey thanks very much for doing this um
couple questions for dr wolanski um dr
wolinski last week you said that we
actually don't know how our rapid tests
perform and how well they predict
whether you're transmissible during the
end of disease but now the cdc guidance
says people who test positive on an
antigen test at day five should continue
to isolate for another five days so i'm
hoping you can explain which is it uh do
these tests serve a purpose to assess
transmissibility uh or not and secondly
uh amid the additions to the new
guidance yesterday uh you say that
people should avoid travel restaurants
and eating around others at home and at
work until 10 10 days
so why wasn't that information included
last week and how do you expect people
to keep track of what they can and can't
do
yeah thank you for that question jeremy
so um first i will say as noted before
the fda has authorized these rapid tests
for early in the disease course the
first seven days they've clarified that
or they've said that these tests are for
qualitative purposes not quantitative
purposes meaning we can't tell how
transmissible you are based on a
positive or negative test
um and that negatives um you know are
often most helpful when we're using them
serially multiple times in a row um that
said after we released our guidance uh
our recommendations uh early last week
it became very clear that people were
interested in using the rapid tests
though not authorized for this purpose
for this purpose after their end of
isolation period and because there was
um
interest in using them for this reason
we then provided guidance on how they
should be used so if one is to take an
extra step and
perform a test at the end of their
five-day isolation period we wanted to
make sure people understood how they
should be interpreted if that test is
positive people should stay home for
those extra five days
um and if that test is negative people
really do need to understand that they
must continue to wear their mask um for
those uh extra five days after um
to complete a 10-day isolation period um
back to you jeff
next question please
let's go to ahmed at reuters
hi yeah thank you um
my question is for uh dr malansky is the
cdc considering ending the practice of
releasing
daily infection accounts for the u.s
given
that there are so many test results that
are not being reported
and are you considering only focusing
on hospitalizations and deaths
thank you yeah thank you for that
question ahmed um
obviously we need to focus not only on
severity of disease and uh importance of
uh our healthcare infrastructure but
also um
case counts are often a leading
indicator because the severity of
disease and healthcare infrastructure
might lag behind what is happening in
case counts so we're thinking through
all of that right now thanks for that
question
next question
let's go to cheyenne haslett at abc news
hi thank you uh this is for jeff i know
the rfp just closed
and exact contracts are still in the
works for uh the 500 million
plan um in january but big picture can
you say the confidence that the rapid
test companies authorized in the us can
actually produce 500 million extra tests
in january for the plan and will those
tests um be coming off of the shelves of
pharmacies at all
no these are additional tests and this
is
made possible by the fact that the fda
across the last few months have
authorized many more
rapid tests so there's a lot more
capacity
for rapid tests uh you know back in
september there were about 50 million
fewer than 50 million a month were now
running above 200 million but with all
the companies that have now been
authorized as the capacity for the us
government to purchase the 500 million
now and not disrupt or in any way
cannibalize the tests that are
on pharmacy shelves and on websites and
used in other settings overall we're
making significant progress on the 500
million as of yesterday as you mentioned
the public contracting process is closed
deliveries of tests
from manufacturers to the us government
will begin over the next week or so
americans will start receiving free
tests in the coming weeks we will set up
a free and easy
system
uh including a new website to get these
tests out to americans obviously this is
an unprecedented action to have a half
billion tests bought by the us
government and distributed for free
and we'll continue to do more and more
to increase access to testing
given the extreme demand that's been
driven by the transmissibility of
omicron
next question
let's go to david lima politico
hi thanks for taking my question um i
wanted to ask uh quest diagnostics
announced last night that its turnaround
time is now on average two to three days
up from one day
um for a lab-based pcr test at our labs
have told me that they're having
challenges
with staffing infections among staff and
difficulty finding and hiring enough
qualified lab techs as a bottleneck not
necessarily the supply chain like
pipette or reagent
chemicals like last time
um i wanted to ask what if anything can
the federal government do to alleviate
staffing issues at labs before
turnaround times continue to
deteriorate i think we need to do um
everything we can across all aspects of
testing
uh you know i think that it's clearly as
i just said in the prior
question there's unprecedented demand
given the transmissibility of omicron
and as the president said we know this
remains frustrating
for people getting tested in many parts
of the country so um
we are working to do all we can and
including setting up additional testing
sites as i mentioned in my opening
comments across many states there are 20
000 free testing sites
fema
is going to go ahead and add sites in
maine maryland delaware texas and
washington states drug stores are
restocking
and starting next week those are the
at-home tests as opposed to the pcrs
that you're asking about
they are restocking and as of next week
we'll be able to have at-home tests
reimbursed by commercial insurance so a
lot's going on with testing as the
specific issue with staffing at the labs
that's something that i'll have the team
look into and we'll get back to you
david
next question
let's go to katherine iran at many care
thank you very much for taking my
question
um on december 23rd uh the cdc issued a
guideline saying that healthcare workers
uh
with covid19 could return to work after
seven days with a negative test
about four days after that
the cdc
issued a guidance not requiring a
negative test after five days
for people to return to work
um
can can dr walensky just explain
the distinction between those two
guidances and whether
the omission of a testing requirement to
emerge from isolation
was driven by the shortage of available
tests
um maybe i'll take that in two parts
first of all um
this has nothing to do with the shortage
of available tests because um you can
see in our quarantine uh guidance that
we actually do recommend a test for
people to emerge from quarantine and we
do anticipate that there will be more
people in quarantine than there are in
isolation but this is to your question
about health care workers
our infection control and prevention
guidance for health care workers is
historically and always much more
conservative than it is for the general
public and that is by design that is
because our health care workers are
routinely caring for people who are
immunosuppressed
routinely caring for vulnerable
populations so it's absolutely the case
that all of our healthcare worker
guidance with regard to cova 19 and all
other transmissible diseases are much
more
restrictive and much more conservative
with regard to return to the work place
for our health care workers
and that's the reason for the
discrepancy
next question
all right a couple more questions let's
go to meg terrell at cnbc
thanks um you know we've been hearing
folks have been noticing that the prices
of rapid tests at retailers like walmart
just went up from the 14
at cost price and the retailers say
that's because this white house program
that held the um tests at cost for three
months has ended um i'm wondering
obviously the 500 million free tests are
coming and we're about to start getting
the reimbursement for the test but was
there any consideration or discussion
about trying to continue keeping these
tests at cost and are you confident that
when the insurers start to reimburse for
the rapid tests that we won't see the
retail prices spike because insurance
will cover them
so uh meg thanks for the question you
are right uh amazon walmart kroger all
stepped up a few months ago and did the
right thing by selling
at home tests for
the past 90 days or so during that
period of time as we've talked about we
have worked to really scale up and
expand the number of at-home tests both
the quantity and the choices and there
are now tests
uh at lower price points including
single-pack tests in addition to that
we have 20 000 free testing sites and we
increase the number of sites each day as
you said
americans will start to get reimbursed
by insurance
and so we can expect that those tests
will be reimbursed by commercial
insurance uh starting uh next week so uh
the 500 million new tests that are going
to become available through the website
those are all going to be free so the
cost of getting a test should be free
um through reimbursement through the 500
million through the 20 million sorry 20
000 sites
for americans who want free
testing next question
last question let's go to sabrina
siddiqui at the wall street journal
uh thank you in our coverage we're
hearing from a lot of parents who have
children under five for whom there's no
vaccine these parents are boosted but
given omicron's transmissibility even
among boosted people i think the
questions they have um are one is there
a more specific set of guidelines for
parents with children under five should
they be avoiding indoor gatherings or
taking additional precautions to protect
their kids and two what do we know about
severity of illness and possibility of
lancome in children under five
let's do the severity piece first dr
fauci you covered some of this earlier
and then dr wolinski on any specific
guidance for parents with kids under
five
yeah again just to reiterate what i said
i believe was on the last slide
that in general omicron appears to be a
less severe disease across the board
but the sheer volume of infections
because of its profound
transmissibility mean that many more
children
will get infected and as many more
children will get infected a certain
proportion of them
usually children that have underlying
comorbidities are going to wind up in
the hospital that is just an
inevitability given the high degree of
transmissibility
we should follow all of the guidelines
of the cdc
one of the best ways to prevent
infection in children
who are not able to be vaccinated
because of their age is to surround the
children with people who are vaccinated
and to do the important things of when
they are out make sure that if they're
old enough to be able to tolerate a mask
put a mask on them particularly in
congregate settings the cdc is very
clear about that just follow those
guidelines doctor let's see anything to
add
i don't have much to add except to say
that the best way to protect your
children under five is to put a mask on
if there are over two to surround
themselves by people who are vaccinated
and then and boosted
and then to take those precautions that
you can as a parent wearing a mask in
public indoor settings but taking all
those layered mitigation strategies so
that you are at lowest risk of bringing
disease home to your children
all right well thank you everybody
talk to you soon thank you
you